London-born actor Robert Pattinson skyrocketed
to fame with the massively popular Twilight
series — and he recently made headlines
when it was announced he'd be playing the
titular role in The Batman.
"And…?"
From modeling gigs to his sometimes dramatic
love life, here’s everything you need to
know about Robert Pattinson.
After honing his craft in several theater
productions, Robert Pattinson landed his first
big break at the age of 17: He was cast as
Cedric Diggory in the 2005 film Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire.
"For a moment there, I thought you were gonna
let him get me."
He chose playing Cedric over attending university,
and the film took his acting career to a whole
new level.
His performance was widely praised, and numerous
publications hailed him as "the next Jude
Law," a label that proved difficult to shake.
In a 2008 interview with the BBC, Pattinson
was asked whether he agreed with that assessment,
and he replied:
"No.
[...] You get a bit of heat and everybody
says you're this, you're that.
Then it dies down.
You just do jobs.
I don't know any actor who's followed through,
when they say he's the next this and then
he actually has become the next that.
I don't get that.
I don't see what the point is."
The fourth Harry Potter film put Robert Pattinson
on the map, but Twilight turned him into a
household name.
Pattison landed the role of Edward Cullen
in a rather roundabout way: He was in Los
Angeles auditioning for a role he assumed
was already in the bag — and wound up bombing
that audition.
In 2017, he told W magazine:
"The next day, it was the Twilight audition,
and I think I was at such a kind of nothing-
to-lose state, it was quite easy for me to
do."
And so he was cast as an unusually sensitive
vampire who falls in love with a young woman
named Bella, portrayed by Kristen Stewart.
The role earned him legions of fans — many
of them teenage girls — but that didn't
stop him from mocking the Twilight franchise
in interviews.
"My entire performance was based on having
extreme discomfort having contact lenses in
your eyes, just like…
It's kinda like that."
"If Edward was not a fictional character,
and you met him in reality, you know, he's
one of those guys, he'd be an axe murderer."
He also wasn't opposed to mocking Stephenie
Meyer, the author of the Twilight novels.
"I was convinced that Stephanie was convinced
she was Bella.
And it was, like, a book that wasn't supposed
to be published."
It sounds like Pattinson has softened his
stance in recent years.
In April 2019, he told USA Today:
"It's lovely now that the mania is not so
intense.
[...] Now the intensity has died down and
it's just very warm memories."
In May 2019, it was announced that Robert
Pattinson would play a young incarnation of
a certain brooding superhero in The Batman,
a film that's set to premiere in 2021.
Rather predictably, the news sent the Twitterverse
into a frenzy, and not everyone was onboard
with the idea.
One user wrote,
"I've never been so disappointed in a #Batman
casting, #RobertPattinson is a horrible choice
to play the character."
Film critic Mike McGranaghan was clearly torn
by the casting choice, tweeting:
"I honestly don't know how to feel about Robert
Pattinson as Batman.
On one hand, I hate the idea, because I can't
even remotely picture him as the Dark Knight.
On the other hand, I absolutely love the idea
for the exact same reason."
Meanwhile, Jimmy Kimmel offered this particularly
hot take:
"If you think about it, it makes sense: He
was a vampire, now he's a bat."
In 2012, Robert Pattinson's relationship with
Kristen Stewart turned him into irresistible
tabloid fodder.
Though they tried to keep the relationship
under wraps, they were forced to come clean
in the wake of a highly publicized scandal.
Stewart finally acknowledged their relationship
after she was photographed being intimate
with then-married director Rupert Sanders,
who worked with Stewart on Snow White and
the Huntsman.
"When a famous actress gets caught cheating
by the paparazzi and then makes a very public
apology, it's no surprise that people everywhere
are reacting with 140-characters or less."
Stewart profusely apologized in a public statement,
writing:
"This momentary indiscretion has jeopardized
the most important thing in my life, the person
I love and respect the most, Rob.
I love him, I love him, I'm so sorry."
Stewart and Pattinson briefly got back together
after the scandal, but they split for good
in 2013.
In 2019, Pattinson suggested that he's on
good terms with Stewart, so perhaps this story
has a happy ending after all.
With his chiseled features, it's not terribly
surprising that Robert Pattinson would try
his hand at modeling.
He told Closer magazine that he left the industry
after four years at the age of 16, explaining:
"When I first started I was quite tall and
looked like a girl, so I got lots of jobs,
because it was during that period where the
androgynous look was cool.
Then, I guess, I became too much of a guy,
so I never got any more jobs.
I had the most unsuccessful modelling career."
In 2010, at the height of Twilight fever,
Pattinson was reportedly offered a huge contract
with Burberry, but he didn't take it.
A source told the Mirror:
"They went to ­Robert but he ­immediately,
politely, turned them down.
As far as Robert sees things he’s an actor
by trade and that’s his art.
He doesn’t want to start becoming a brand
or anything."
If that's true, Pattinson obviously had a
change of heart just a few short years later.
In 2013, he became the face of Dior Homme,
and he's been working with the brand ever
since.
As it turns out, Jude Law was the face of
Dior Homme just a few years prior — which
means Robert Pattinson became "the next Jude
Law" after all.
"What's he got, better than me?!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.